my first guest of course has starred in
numerous films including real steel
and the x-men movies now you can see him
in his one-man show
hugh jackman back on broadway at the
broadhurst theater please welcome
hugh jackman
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
oh my god
that was that's truly
sir you're a sweater yeah
please tell me that's not what i look
like
oh no that's horrifying that was
terrible out of the business right now
i'm sorry
two minute impersonation it was very
good it was very good and horrifying for
me uh
you know thank you so much for being
here it's great uh
great to have you back oh thank you very
much
thank you thank you good to be nice to
be here you know i
um i was asking around about the last
couple days because you were coming on
the show and i keep hearing the same
thing over and over again people say you
are known as probably the nicest actor
in the business okay
goodbye everybody
it's the conan mask that changed you
know what you do i mean
uh that that little indiscretion aside
right there you're known as being
incredibly nice and i'm wondering how
you deal with
you're here you're on broadway you're
walking around the streets everyone
wants your autograph how do you deal
with photo requests
autograph requests i learned from the
legend george clooney i saw george
clooney at an event once
at the waldorf astoria and look at any
point you think you may be
in movies of some level the moment
george clooney moves in you realize
you're not you're way down here
and he just got mobbed and he has this
particular style
um uh let me show you sure yeah come on
okay i need you out who am i am i an
attractive woman
if well who am i in this scenario you
can just be you you're a big george
clooney fan
yeah i like a woman though okay okay can
you be a woman
because you always like to be the one
absolutely okay i'm george
hey it's so lovely to meet you it's
really terrific thank you so much
and it's hi george [ __ ] thank you now
what is that
it's all about the eyes isn't it he gets
like uncomfortably close he gets in
there and he never stops moving
[Applause]
you see people going for their phone
right because they want that they want
the autograph they want a picture and
they go for it and then he's there
and before they've got their head he's
gone and they're happy yeah this is
they're transfixed yeah it's just much
quicker to be polite
yeah it seems like it's working um i
want to ask you about uh this show
hugh jackman back on broadway i'm
curious you must have you're doing this
big show are there people that
that come and and they expect to see
wolverine you know what i mean that
huge x-men fans that are coming to the
show and they think yeah i'm going to
get some wolverine here and it's not i
do wolverine monologues for the first
act and i want to be very clear i'm
kidding
uh yes there's no doubt some people do
come and in fact last week uh it was
obvious to me some people came under
duress because it was the world series
and so it's so obvious to tell the guys
who like took a bullet
and just got dragged along by their wife
and i remember last week it was
thursday night game six that classic
game six right so
this guy was sitting in the front row
and he was sort of being polite he was
nice and
i did a little joke about the baseball
and he's like right there and i said
you want to know the score don't you and
i guess yeah so i went on stage and i
grabbed him the score and i said don't
worry i'm going to look after you so i
was during the show i kept getting the
score and then i forgot about
it for about an hour and i looked down
at him and he was asleep
and i said hey
he goes yeah you want to know the score
he goes yeah literally 100 people yelled
out the score
it's 99 top of the 10th or whatever it
was it was like
no one's watching my show no they're all
there watching yeah
good show yeah thanks with the and conan
yeah
same here even the ones no come on no
and you know what they're even the ones
with the signs the guy with the mask has
a little lcd screen in the mask
he's watching breaking bad on his uh
unless it works underwater
no he doesn't i'm going to pay you a
compliment you're a fantastic actor a
great performer
but nobody nobody in the world does a
better topless
primal scream than hugh jackman don't
you think that's true
nobody
you know the the rage you channel when
you are
uh topless is incredible
thank you i have worked very hard on
that we actually for your benefit and
for the benefit
of everyone watching we put together a
montage of hugh jackman
primal screams let's take a look
[Applause]
these
[Applause]
that way come on hugh time to get up
[Laughter]
those people back there don't even know
what show they're at
later like we saw a really unusual wendy
williams show that was crazy
it was very different she had her
elaborate science yeah
now uh you know what i i uh unlike a lot
of people i talked to i
was thinking about it today the range of
stuff that you get to do in your career
as a performer and you have the
dreaming no i'm serious the different
roles that you play
and action and musical comedy everything
it seems like you do it all
and you did uh the dvd release came out
today
yeah of one of your work snowflower and
the secret fan which is an unusual
project yeah
it was a great project to be involved
with it's a chinese film so i got to
shoot in shanghai
i play a small part in it but i got to
sing in chinese in that i play like this
nightclub owner who just likes to get up
and take them well you want me to do a
little bit for you
no no that was it that was just for
that was a yes no no
no they were so great so this is you
singing this is you had to get ahead to
learn
i literally took me two months to learn
this song phonetically it it is so
difficult i think mandarin is supposed
to be the hardest language maybe to
master
so you you had to learn a song in
mandarin yeah so it took me like two
months
i i will never forget this song for as
long as i live do you want to do a
little bit i'd love to hear it yeah
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
guys
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
come on
join us
[Music]
hugh jackman
[Applause]